and to the extent that he is dealing
with management of pain there may
eventually be some good news for Todd
Gurley and the rest of the NFL players
who are always dealing with pain issues
when you consider what they do for a
living the NFL and the NFL Players
Association announced on Monday an
agreement to form a committee that will
study alternate therapies for management
of pain including Cris marijuana yeah
the first time the NFL acknowledging
that maybe this is a good idea you know
stepping away from the collectively
bargained right to tell players thou
shalt not smoke weed and to suspend them
for years at a time if they do the NFL
recognizing maybe it's in the best
interest of the sport to find a way to
back off from this prohibition on the
use of marijuana and basically give the
players who need it a medical card and
really what the threshold would have to
be very low to have the pain necessary
to use marijuana because they're all in
pain throughout the course of the season
right the threshold is very low to get
all weepy opioids I know that and man
there are a whole lot more dangerous for
your body than certainly smoking
marijuana is and again yes I think the
NFL should exhaust all avenues as far as
finding better ways to help players deal
with pain management and healing their
body
hey we've heard guys like Brett Favre
who had the opioid addictions when he's
playing I know I had some Ekta mates
that you know dealt with issues there as
far as getting off the addiction pattern
and all that of pills that they had
become accustomed to popping through the
end of their career because they were
trying to just make it happen on a daily
basis and just wanted to get through
that day so oh let me pop a vicodin let
me pop an anti-inflammatory let me pop
this now that the days over and yeah it
not only just ruins your body it ruins
your stomach it messes with the
chemistry of your brain and hey one why
bite off the nose despite the face - I
mean we miss a key important players in
the NFL every year over guys that I know
have broken the rules of what they are
in the NFL but you know again if alcohol
is gonna be legal then I don't see how
we can argue that marijuana is not legal
at this point and I'm glad that the NFL
seems like they're go
in the right direction and Chris I've
noticed over the past year the NFL has
softened in its application of the rules
to guys like Josh Gordon martavis Bryant
Randy Gregory even though all three are
currently suspended they had multiple
incidents while returning from a minimum
suspension of a year still in stage
three where supposedly one false move
gets you suspended for another year
minimum the NFL has been working with
these guys because I think the NFL
understands what's going on here and I
think finally someone at 3:45 Park
Avenue developed a sense of self
awareness on this issue instead of
trying to cram something down the
union's throat where you get a
concession for a retreat on the
marijuana prohibition just realize it's
the right thing to do yeah smart for
everybody let's come up with a way to do
P you know Chris there's one wrinkle
left here that could get a little
awkward there are several states where
the NFL currently does business Texas
Tennessee Georgia North Carolina Indiana
and Wisconsin that still have a complete
ban on marijuana use yeah what do you do
to get your players in a position where
they can use medical marijuana in states
where it's still illegal
yeah that's tricky I mean the first
thing I want to say would to those
states is get a clue get up with the
time there's other things that are legal
in those states where I want to go whoa
that's legal but damn you know they're
smoking something that's gonna put you
on the couch and make you eat a bag of
chips whoa we can't let that be legal so
yeah again that that is going to be the
million dollar question right Mike how
does the NFL really realistically
navigate through that issue I mean I ask
you mr. lawyer can you really do that I
mean how would they do it first of all
and I don't know if this is a product of
the marijuana it's 2019 NOT 2018 but
been even more reason to get with the
times I think what they need to do is
they need to aggressively lobby in those
states and they need to already start or
if they haven't started they should
start now trying to lay the foundation
to get Medical Marijuana authorization
in place in those states now it's not
like you're gonna dangle Relocation
because what the Texans are the Cowboys
are gonna move the Packers are gonna
move right nobody's moving over it but
let me tell you if it would be
strange state of affairs if you had the
ability on every other team to smoke
marijuana right the Cowboys Texans cults
Titans Panthers Falcons Packers are out
in the cold
good luck signing free okay you're right
exactly right there's gonna be guys
we're go okay but the Cowboys or you
know some team in California okay I
might choose California of all things
are equal they're the money's pretty
much the same you're right that's gonna
be a detractor there but hey we've heard
some stand-up individuals that have
played in the NFL you know kind of
talked about marijuana and CBD oil in a
glowing way that I think we have to take
it to an account that it really that
helps people I know I got ex friends who
believe in CBD oil and smoking you know
marijuana to help with their aches and
pains we heard a guy like Calvin Johnson
who I don't believes ever been in any
shape form or even close to trouble in
his whole life he's talking about it how
it's helping his body so I think it just
makes too much sense you know to find
another way to help some of these
players out who are getting beat to crap
during the season and you know people
ask me all the time you hate the NFL you
criticize the NFL it's like I love the
NFL
I want the NFL to be as good as it can
be and we try to highlight areas where
we think the NFL could be better and the
fact that the NFL has found a way to
just start down this path of doing the
right thing the NFL deserves to be
applauded because for a long time the
NFL dug in and I remember when States
first started to legalize up
recreational purposes the NFL said well
it's still illegal under federal law and
they were gonna cling to that until the
federal government drops its prohibition
on marijuana use good to see that the
NFL realizes there's benefit there to
the players Chris and it's the right
thing to do yes and last thing because
this is something that's been kind of
like annoying me you know we talked
about marijuana and we talked about Oh a
federal law and it's not legal there you
know what okay I get that and I'm not
trying to even defend that what drives
me crazy is federal law never gets
brought up with with with PE D little
use that to me is one thing that annoys
me as far as substance abuse in the NFL
and PD is we go off
gosh that guy was just cheating trying
to make his muscles bigger like a
Patrick Peterson but we never forget
that a lot of the times they're taking
substances that are illegal in our
country too they have broken the law let
alone tried to cheat us and showing us
that there are not the talented that
they are trying to claim they are
because they're chemically enhanced I
don't know why I'm saying that it just
bothers me at times because federal law
gets associated with marijuana but then
guys cheat and set bad examples for
young kids and do it illegally and
nobody talks about the federal law with
that so sorry I just had to get that off
my chest no it's good and it's it's
smart and it's smart that the NFL is
finally acknowledging that there's
benefit here to the players that
marijuana is safer than opioid use and
let's drop this this Big Brother routine
where they want a police and legislate
what guys do in the off season right
seven months they're left to their own
devices it was it was dumb in the first
place I understand why they did it it
was it was a reflection of the times and
the war on drugs and all that stuff and
it was a a PR thing but now it's times
have changed and it's time for the NFL
to change and we're good to sit the door
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports